it never occurred to me that I could
that I could actually have a career as
an actor little in a career on film it
seemed the most unlikely thing that's
partly geographical you know I come from
as far away from any kind of film
industry as you could possibly imagine
in those days now nowadays people make
films in New Zealand but they didn't
then so the idea of actually being a
real actor in real films was unthinkable
so I sort of learned on the job and I
kind of stumbled into film really I was
acting University and then I found that
I could get the odd part time you know
the odd job in in the theatre but there
wasn't enough work as an actor in New
Zealand those days so I worked for a
documentary film company government
documentary film company for about seven
years and they would give me time off I
would go away and do other people's
little films and then one day Roger
Donaldson asked me to be the lead in a
feature film and I did that I wasn't
very good in it but it was a feature
film and no one had done a feature film
in New Zealand for 17 years then I went
back to work for a year and then I was
offered a job in Australia and I thought
I'm going to resign my job as a rather
indifferent documentary filmmaker and
I'm going to go to Australia and see if
I can make a living as an actor so I
started quite late of 29 when I got to
Australia so that was when I first
committed to being a full-time actor and
to my complete surprise I've been sort
of in work ever since no one's more
surprised than me walking onto film set
was not in any way I'm familiar to me
because I was working in documentaries
so I was familiar with everything about
film hearing and I've always been I've
always been comfortable on a film set
I've always been comfortable with film
crews the camera I've always regarded as
my close ally if not a close friend I'm
always nervous the first day I walk on a
set always but I think if you're not a
little nervous then you're probably
complacent and you should probably go
home and work up a bit of nervousness I
also love working with a new bunch of
actors every time sometimes I you know
you get to have the privilege of working
with people on multiple occasions
sometimes three films with Willem Dafoe
for instance so we're good friends but
it's always great to have a new bunch of
actors I love the company of actors I
like sitting around telling stories with
actors and listening to other people's
stories and and being in unfamiliar
places and exploring new worlds actors
always talked about making choices and
thinks the truth is that most actors
really don't have as much choices as
they'd like you know sometimes there's
four scripts on your desk and sometimes
there's nothing
Soniya script comes through the door and
you think I've never been there before
and there's not a great part but maybe I
can make something of it what do I look
for in a part obviously complexity and
if the complexity isn't there I like to
make it complex if I can I don't really
see any characters as being particularly
black or white I don't think there's
such a such a thing as a perfectly good
person or a perfectly bad person I think
someone you know every villain has its
reasons and every good guy has his flaws
I like ambivalence I think it's more
interesting to play and if it's not
there I'll try and put put some in see
if I get away with it a lot of directors
think casting is really it
ask the rack guy and they know what to
do and there's a sort of sense in there
in some ways you know so when you start
a new project it's always best to be
prepared because you don't know if
you're going to be directed or not but I
think a lot of directors miss the
opportunity of collaborating with it
with actors actors love to be you know
have a discussion about and see if we
can contribute something that perhaps no
one's thought about before but very
often directors sit behind their
monitors and kind of let you do what you
have to do so you have to be prepared
for that and but I much prefer to be on
a set where a director wants to talk to
me where you where where we where
genuinely becomes a collaboration and as
the most as much more fun to be directed
I think it's a lot to be said for the
long form television and there's sort of
great opportunities for actors to build
characters because you've got you've got
more time to to work with that guy
whoever he is I actually kind of prefer
the speed of something like peaky
blinders where you're where you're doing
an hour every 9 or 10 days it's pretty
amazing I mean that would be that's
unthinkable in the feature film well but
from an actor's point of view you're
working really you hardly have time to
sit down you're working like the
clappers and there's no time to get
bored and sit around your trailer and
get to scrunt 'old a lot of disgruntled
people sitting in trailers
Plan B is really a good idea so I would
always say learn how to do something
else it's a tough business if you're not
in regular work you need to know how to
do something else of course there's
always the other there's Plan C which is
generate the work yourself
for instance you know Taika Waititi who
wrote directed and for the wielder
people as generated his own work make
the flight of the conchords guys all
these people write and direct and and
produce their own work and that's
fantastic so and there are so many
platforms now that you can get that you
can get started on you couldn't make a
film on our ipod and put it on YouTube
and the next thing you know you're
directing the Avengers number seven this
is what can happen so that you know
don't wait for the phone to ring you you
pick up the phone and do it yourself
just because I've had a lot of
experience it certainly doesn't mean
that there are certain things that I'm
really getting right or or or nailing I
mean I would almost hope the opposite
because I want to always be finding new
ways of being able to collaborate and
being able to be included and involved
and excited and passionate